donc je vais pas critiquer de chéri mais
franchement c'est celui qui fait les
têtes les plus étranges dans l'équipe et
je vous préviens la prod a déjà il part
avec une tête étrangers
on aime ta différence alors vous allez
voir ça commence comme le rire le plus
long de l'histoire de la télé ça
s'arrête et après je ne sais pas ce qui
se passe cyril et s'adresser à gérard
louvin a super bien même ce que fait
encore chaud
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
je suis en est encore une fois
je suis pas langue de bois j'aimerais
dire non parce que ça ne se voit pas et
c'est là que si les séries se voit pas
du tout je savais pas moi je ne savais
même pas moi même j'aurais mieux fait de
fermer ma gueule
[Rires]
partouche